so earlier this week uh donald trump's
attorney rudy giuliani tested positive
for coronavirus and now
another trump attorney jenna ellis has
tested positive as well
these are the primary two trump lawyers
who have been waging this completely
pointless and bogus baseless war to
overturn the election results based on
imaginary voter fraud jonathan
swann from axios reporting on the story
tweeting that
president trump's lawyer jenna ellis has
informed
associates she has coronavirus multiple
sources tell axio
stirring west wing fears after she
attended a senior
staff christmas party on friday so a few
different things here number one
is this surprising no you know that
she's not been taking precautions she's
not been staying home
she's not been avoiding indoor crowds
she's not been wearing a mask
um she and rudy giuliani have been
flying around the country
daily in a pandemic since the election
during the worst period we've had since
the beginning of the pandemic
and also attending at least jenna ellis
did
a white house party and other larger
events they're frequently maskless at
these so-called hearings and events so
rudy got it
jenna got it and now there's panic at
the white house because she was with a
huge swath of white house staffers on
friday and that may end up becoming
another one of these super spreader
events
she reportedly had no mask there and
it's all a complete
and total mess now of course i wish no
one ill
i hope she recovers even though she's
part of the problem i'd never wish
illness or death upon anyone
what i want to mention is that there is
something sort of poetic
about the virus that they ignored
and didn't deal with now shutting down
their hair-brained ill-advised attempts
to overturn
the results of an election that donald
trump simply lost partially
because of his his mishandling of the
virus
by infecting his legal team i'm not
saying it's karma i'm not saying it's
divine intervention i'm just saying
there's something
ironic poetic whatever that part of the
reason trump lost
is his mishandling of the virus that
same virus is now what is going to
interfere
with trump making a legal case that he
should be the winner anyway despite
having lost
now that rudy is sidelined jenna ellis's
sideline
does this sort of naturally force
the voter fraud nonsense the hearings
the legal filings to kind of peter out
or are they going to try to push it
remotely
via zoom one report is that rudy
sometime this week is going to be
joining another one of these hearings
remotely from his hospital room now by
the way
that's a whole other issue um some
leaked i guess you would call them
exchanges between rudy giuliani
and trump's doctor have been reported on
and the allegation is that trump's
doctor
called rudy and said rudy go to the
hospital when rudy tested positive
and rudy said i feel fine why would i
don't i don't want to go to the hospital
and trump's doctor reportedly told rudy
listen rudy
just go we can get this dealt with in
three days by giving you the same
treatment
trump got and presumably what this means
is
if you take someone and you monitor them
immediately
you monitor their oxygen levels you scan
them regularly
at the sign of any decreased uh uh
and any type of any concerning vital
sign
you immediately deal with that so that
the body can continue fighting the virus
there's no question is the point
that if everybody could get the
treatment that trump got and that now
rudy giuliani is getting just by hey i'm
going to check myself into a hospital
and get
top treatments and best doctors and all
of that way more people would survive
and we know that
intuitively and it appears as though
they're saying it to rudy in uncertain
terms we can deal with this in three
days if we do what we did
with donald trump and monitoring you for
72 hours
wouldn't probably apply to everybody but
it would save a lot of lives if
everybody could could get that
but coronavirus causing the end of this
absurd campaign to overturn the results
of an election that trump lost in part
because he ignored the virus early on
that really is something i mean you know
what they said was 15 cases that would
soon be zero back in april
has now infected trump trump's son don
jr
trump's other son barron trump uh don
jr's girlfriend kimberly guilfoyle
trump's personal personal lawyer his
campaign lawyer his press secretary a
bunch of republican senators and on and
on and on and i caught a discussion on
right wing
on in a right-wing internet forum
yesterday where right-wingers
were suspicious about why is it that
when prominent democrats get the virus
it isn't
covered by the so-called fake news media
now the reason for that is that it's
mostly prominent republicans that are
getting the virus because democrats
are taking the virus more seriously
imagine at this point at this stage of
the game
having the lack of ability to reflect on
something like that
and coming away with the idea that the
the media covers up
prominent democratic covet cases no it's
that it's mostly
prominent republicans getting it because
they're doing things like what rudy
giuliani
and and jenna ellis have been doing and
people wondering
is she going to get the same privilege
as rudy and getting checked into a
top-notch hospital for observation as a
precaution
chris christie was able to do it of
course trump was able to do it i have no
idea
but what i can tell you for sure is that
so many americans
would have survived the virus had
they been able to do the same thing
many of whom were behaving far more
responsibly than rudy giuliani and jenna
ellis i mean
tragically um there are people who
wear a mask every time they leave their
home work from home
do nothing other than go to the grocery
store and they've gotten the virus and
some of them have died
they didn't have access to this type of
treatment rudy giuliani flies around the
country
waging a bogus voter fraud case shutting
down the arizona state legislature due
to exposing those folks
and he just gets to check in and get the
absolute top treatment you know it's
part of that two-tier system that we
talk about